bonsoir fabrice et faites moi merci
d'être avec nous ce qui frappe quand on
écoute ce sujet c'est cette opacité
autour de la politique de facebook de
modération précisément comment
l'expliquer il faut bien comprendre que
ces documents que s'est procuré le
guardian ce n'est pas la première fois
que ce type de document fuite ces
destinées à des armes et de modérateur
qui vont appliquer de façon extrêmement
mécanique avec aucune forme de réflexion
aucune porte de jugement un ensemble de
règles de façon modérée une quantité
infinie de contenu on n'est pas du tout
dans une logique de justice avec un
débat contradictoire
un juge qui réfléchit à la sanction qui
va prendre
c'est même exactement inverse et c'est
l'avenir de la gouvernance de la liberté
d'expression dans tout un tas de pays
dont la france c'est précisément ce que
la loi via voulait faire confier la
régulation de la liberté d'expression à
les acteurs tels que facebook
on voit l'envers du décor c'est toujours
très intéressant de voir cette
alternative complète à la justice que
les démocraties n'ont l'habitude de
côtoyer et si l'occasion de vraiment se
demander si ces dernières qu'on peut
aller c'est surtout que quand on
décortique un petit peu ce test texte on
se rend compte qu'il ya des subtilités
qui confine à la turbie comment les
appliquer elles sont confiné à l'absurde
mais il faut aussi bien comprendre que
c'est un texte qui s'applique à tout un
tas de pays tout un tas de culture tout
un tas de juridictions différentes et
qui essaye de faire quelque chose qui va
conduire à à peu près tout le monde est
de toute évidence ça ne fonctionne pas
mais facebook ne peut pas se permettre
n'a pas les moyens de faire du local ne
peut vraiment pas appliquer la loi
localement ça n'est pas un stock de
justice
il ne peut pas se permettre de dépenser
ce que représente une véritable justice
et donc il va sous traiter à des
entreprises qui ne sont pas facebook et
donc avec une pression financière
spectaculaire sur le rendement sur
l'efficacité de cette modération de
façon à se débarrasser des problèmes et
en optimiser le coût forcément le
résultat est très discutable car il ya
un chapitre aussi sur les causes
politiques controversées voire illégales
dans certains pays
c'est fait l'objet d'un long
développement dans ce livre je cite avec
des règles interdisent la justification
d'actions violentes par le fait qu'une
cause soit légitime enfin là on apprend
quelque chose de délicat qui décide que
c'est légitime
on est extrêmement c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement délicat
en temps normal à l'époque du printemps
arabe si ces règles avaient été en
application le printemps arabe n'aurait
peut-être pas démarré en tout cas pas de
la façon dont il a démarré sur facebook
il ya énormément de remous sociaux qui
peuvent être tués dans l'oeuf par ce
type de règles et on imagine malgré tout
que en termes de stabilité sociale c'est
quelque chose que beaucoup d'états ont
demandé à facebook a commencé par l'état
américain
oui avec une illustration j'allais venir
avec donald trump qui a été assez mal
traités ars raison sociale et les autres
bailleurs
il a été maltraité mais il a été aussi
porté aux nues et aussi on croit à la
ferc un budget à l'éthique à sérent
grande partie avec facebook il a été élu
donc ça s'est mal terminée c'est une
belle histoire d'amour qui s'est très
mal terminé donald trump va rebondir
dans d'autres réseaux sociaux
n'ayons pas peur oui oui justement il a
annoncé cette semaine qu'il lancera sa
propre plateforme les géants du web
doivent s'en inquiéter on va voir ça va
être un épisode intéressant parce que
facebook et laisser les réseaux sociaux
d'une façon générale ne sont pas en
odeur de sainteté le grand public a fini
par comprendre que tout ça a été
extrêmement dangereux et que tout ça
pouvait avoir un impact profond sur les
sociétés et les abîmes et de façon
vraiment significative
est-ce que donald trump va réussir à
amener vers lui énormément de gens aient
constitué une autre bulle à d'autres
média social ça va être très intéressant
à observer et si c'est le cas ça sera
quelque chose de redoutables peut-on
craindre un avenir des réseaux sociaux
définis justement qu'en fonction des
courants politiques
c'est déjà quelque part en partie le cas
les réseaux sociaux enferme les gens
dans des des formes de bulles des silos
informationnel qui sont très souvent
connoté politiquement le fait que yoichi
en et plusieurs ne change finalement pas
grand chose sur ces réseaux sociaux
la plupart d'entre nous sommes enfermés
dans des bulles qui sont
homogène politiquement parlant ce qui
donne effectivement 7 sp de toute
puissance où les gens sont persuadés
d'avoir raison parce qu'effectivement
ils sont au milieu de gens qui ont une
très grande homogénéité de penser et à
force de ne voir que des gens qui
pendent son qu'ils pensent de la même
façon que d'eau on a l'impression
d'avoir la vérité universelle et surtout
dans une vaste majorité y compris si on
est un tout petit groupe minoritaire
c'est l'un des effets de ces douze
informationnelle et depuis très
longtemps
les réseaux sociaux sont très connotées
politiquement et justement fabrice
appelle moi comment favoriser une forme
de mixité dans les opinions restent
avant c'est compliqué parce que c'est
visiblement contrat n'est pas avec les
modèles économiques de ces plateformes
donc il faudrait déjà se trouver un
autre modèle économique un modèle
économique qui ne favorise pas le clash
la confrontation un modèle économique
qui ferait que les gens s'accorderait
sur d'autres logiques
j'ai peur que le problème ne viennent
pas tant des plateformes le problème
vient de la rencontre entre ces
algorithmes sociaux qui nous envahit
c'est qui qui régule de plus en plus
notre vie sociale surtout en période de
confinement et puis la société telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui en france et
ailleurs et la problématique vraiment
être plutôt à regarder du côté des
sociétés
on est en cependant dans une société qui
pour reprendre l'analyse de jérôme
fourquet est en train de s'arracher
elysées avec des petits îlots fait de
gens qui pensent de la même façon qui
s'isole et qui reste dans un entre soi
le problème et social l'algorithme ne
fait que révéler tout ça merci beaucoup
fabrice a fait le point ce spécialiste
des médias professeur à sciences po
d'avoir été avec nous